comment nos enfants seront élevés dans
l'avenir discussions tous azimuts en ce
moment lionel jospin le ministre de
l'éducation est notre invité la guerre
de la morue suite situation de plus en
plus tendu à saint pierre et miquelon
enquête à saint malo du font partie et
chalutiers
chaque jour apporte de nouvelles
révélations sur les affaires les
enquêteurs américains privilégient
maintenant la piste suisse françois
mitterrand chez les bulgares deux jours
de visite officielle dans ce pays qui
est le plus sûr allié de l'union
soviétique procédure et elle l'heure du
réquisitoire les hooligans bien sûr mais
aussi les hommes chargés de la sécurité
du stade
bonsoir ô combien de marins combien de
capitaines qui sont partis joyeux pour
des courses lointaines
voilà deux verres force élèves de victor
hugo que doivent méditer les marins de
deux chalutier breton
ceux qui sont partis à la pêche au large
de saint pierre et miquelon à l'arrivée
toute une population qui s'est dressé
contre parce qu'il venait pêcher dans
les eaux de l'archipel
résultat une guerre de la morue dont on
ne voit pas bien l'issue hier nous avons
raconté ce qui se passait à saint pierre
et miquelon et bien voici ce qu'on en
pense à saint malo le port d'où sont
partis les chalutiers nicolas jacobs ce
reportage
la grande hermine et empêche à saint
pierre est pour beaucoup de mal on a
cette nouvelle résonne comme un faible
résistance tout saint malo est suspendu
aux liaisons radio avec le navire
enfin les tout à fait solidaire avec toi
bien sûr un hacker à saint malo le
joseph roty décharge il arrive de saint
pierre après une pêche de trois mois
c'était la première campagne du matelot
rochelle 18 ans qui ne comprend pas ce
conflit soudain lui avait rencontré des
st pierré amicaux
je me suis fait des amis d'abord qu'on a
fait escale à fait me suis fait
plusieurs minutes où on était vraiment
bien il nous comprenez il disait bombe à
chacun gagne sa croûte
bon ben vous alliez votre route de votre
bord nous est notre groupe de musiciens
de la douleur je comprends pas
ce n'était pas comme ça dans les cales
du joseph roty 900 tonnes de cabillaud
congelés une très belle pêche mais qui
correspond aux quotas préviennent
d'emblée les malouins est méritée
ajoute-t-il et le ton se durcit on met
en cause la compétence des st pierré
rien à rien que la semaine de noël
je fais 40 445 tonnes de poissons et en
plus j'avais beaucoup de plateau
canadien avec nous mais les saint
pierrais peu où il était absent
les quotas qu'est-ce qui les a acquis
les quotas c'est bien aux pères et nos
grands pères nos ancêtres de façon il a
fait des siècles qui en a il a toujours
il y en aura toujours
encore faut-il savoir le partage et les
collègues les malouins sont d'autant
plus déterminés à faire front qu'ils
voient fondre leur flotte de grande
pêche 14 bateaux en 75 il n'en reste que
quatre aujourd'hui les conserver relève
de l'énergie du désespoir et les femmes
de marins se mobilisent un emploi en mer
donne quatre emplois à terre donc ça
malo va ce sera une ville morte
on va bouger est en france et on apprend
on est bien déterminée ne trouve pas ça
se peut qu'on tente de s'inspirer du
tout et qui comprennent peut-être une
solution tout de même dans ce douloureux
conflit tout à l'heure l'armateur des
bateaux malouin était en effet reçu à
matignon pour tenter de trouver une
solution à ce problème
il a accepté de faire un geste
d'apaisement et de retirer son bateau
voilà les derniers développements de
cette affaire
les affaires avec un grand a encore et
toujours chaque jour apporte de
nouvelles révélations sur cette fameuse
affaire pechiney une affaire de fraude
en bourse vous le rappelle hier c'était
la piste moyen-orientale qui était
privilégiée aujourd'hui les enquêteurs
américains montrent la suisse du doigt
c'est de ce côté là qu aurait eu lieu le
plus gros de la fraude
françoise joly car chazal c'est ce
document qui aujourd'hui permet d'y voir
un peu plus clair dans la sphère
pechiney rédigé par la haine ici le
gendarme de la bourse américaine
il aurait été transmis à son homologue
français la cob
dans ce rapport en première ligne un
pays la suisse et trois sociétés
financières c'est pareil corée transiter
plus de la moitié des titres de la
société triangle échanger
irrégulièrement à new york
une de ces sociétés la banque populaire
suisse et même très près
six de nos succursales en suisse a
acheté en tout et surtout sur cette même
action mais pour compte de clients cette
phase critique pendant laquelle il y a
eu délit d'initié c'est à dire juste
avant l'annoncé officielle de l'accord
pechiney triangle le rapport des
américains n'en écarte pas pour autant
la piste moyen-orientale rien ne prouve
en effet que l'on ne retrouve pas
derrière ces banques suisses certains
hommes d'affaires libanais qui démontre
encore eu de fuite mais il faut chercher
les fuites ailleurs que chez moi il y
avait beaucoup de gens au courant il y
avait des gens chez péchiney il y avait
des gens chez triangle
il y avait des gens sur leurs banquiers
il y avait des gens chez le représentant
il y avait plusieurs films d'avocat il y
avait les correspondants de ce film
d'alix d'avocats dans d'autres pays
ça fait beaucoup de monde surtout la
dernière semaine la semaine où il ya eu
les achats les plus importants je peux
vous affirmer qu'il y avait plus de 100
personnes au courant aux états unis
comme je le dis souvent pourquoi
chercher toujours la piste française
il ya peut-être une piste française il
ya peut-être une piste suisse il ya
peut-être une piste ibanez
mais il ya aussi peut-être une piste
américaine ce soir les questions les
plus importantes restent posées qui a
acheté et qui a informé qu'ils sont les
initiés suite des grandes manoeuvres
dans l'enseignement ce matin lionel
jospin a présenté aux syndicats
d'enseignants ces propositions pour
revaloriser la condition d'enseignants
alors nous allons y revenir puisque le
ministre de l'éducation est notre invité
mais d'abord un retour en arrière sur la
loi d'orientation qui devrait
transformer l'enseignement demain il
faut dire tout de suite que les
réactions à cette loi d'orientation
présenté depuis le début de la semaine
ont été plutôt positives contenu de
cette loi d'orientation ou plutôt
comment nos enfants seront éduqués
demain chantal kimmerlin huit grands
objectifs résume le projet éducatif du
gouvernement il devrait être atteint
d'ici dix ans aucun jeune ne devrait
sortir de l'école sans diplôme au moins
égale ainsi ap un bep ou un pack l'âge
mais de l'écolier français est la plus
longue d'europe les horaires devraient
être revues pour alléger l'après midi
l'année scolaire serait divisé en cinq
périodes de travail de durée comparable
séparés par quatre temps de repos
suffisamment long les matières
enseignées serait révisé régulièrement
par un conseil général des programmes
d'enseignement
les examens seraient simplifiées au
profit d'un contrôle continu sur toute
l'année
épreuves écrites et propre orale les
redoublements devrait être de plus en
plus exceptionnel et les parents
seraient associés aux décisions
d'orientation des moyens budgétaires
supplémentaires ont été fixées 12
milliards de rallonge pour les deux
premières années 89 et 90 l'idée forte
les professeurs seraient récompensés de
leur mérite par des indemnités liées à
des tâches et des missions pédagogiques
et périscolaire voilà donc les
principales dispositions de cette loi
d'orientation à l'armée sioniste si vous
voulez bien on va essayer de rester très
très concret parce que je crois que les
détails techniques intéresse pas
vraiment les français alors première
question sur les redoublements vous
dites il ne faut plus que les enfants
redouble mais vous ne craignez pas qu'en
faisant ça si on le fait tous placés en
classe supérieure
il va on va faire baisser le niveau non
il faut que les redoublements soit
exceptionnel et plus exactement ce que
nous proposons c'est que si un enfant
qu'on doit suivre de plus près il ya
d'autres mesures concrètes qui vont dans
ce sens
finalement au bout du cycle n'arrive pas
à être au niveau
nous ne proposons pas qui redouble sa
classe mais qu'il fasse une année de
plus éventuellement donc se passe pas
automatiquement mais en concentrant ses
efforts sur les matières où il y avait
des problèmes sur là où il avait un
retard à rattraper
autre question monsieur le ministre à
propos des rythmes scolaires j'aimerais
vous nous donner quelques précisions
vous voulez une journée mieux adaptée
alors comment va s'organiser cette
journée et surtout est-ce que vous allez
la réduire vous avez entendu c'est la
plus longue d'europe six heures pour le
primaire alors comment vous allez
l'organiser on peut pas réfléchir
seulement sur la journée si on réfléchit
pas aussi sur la semaine et sur l'année
parce que si on devait raccourcir la
journée ce n'est pas encore décidé
il faudrait alors que l'année soit
éventuellement plus longue s'il faut
quand même qu'il y a
d'apprentissage ils soient suffisants et
notre journée plutôt trop longue et
notre année peut-être un peu trop
courtes bien donc il faut réfléchir aux
choses ensemble mais dans la journée
nous pensons qu'il faut mieux équilibrée
d'une part les apprentissages qui sont
faits en cours et d'autre part ce que
j'appellerai les études dirigées le
suivi proche de l'élève
le travail en groupe de travail toute
une partie d'acquisitions des savoirs et
des apprentissages qui se fait davantage
suivi vous voyez davantage aidés par les
enseignants alors autre question très
très pratique vous allez le voir cette
fois ci c'est une mère de famille une
mère de famille de trois enfants qui
vous pose deux questions écoutez bien
premièrement nos enfants dans les lycées
vivent dans des classes surchargées
ce ne sont pas de bonnes conditions de
travail ni pour eux ni pour leurs
enseignants et j'aimerais savoir quelle
mesure monsieur spa compte prendre pour
améliorer la situation de la rentrée
prochaine
deuxièmement on nous dit que nos enfants
ne savent pas lire en fin de cm2 et
j'aimerais savoir quelle mesure monsieur
j'ose pas compte prendre pour qu'il ne
soit plus en situation d'échec dès
l'entrée en sixième alors premièrement
classes surchargées s'est passablement
les mesures que je compte prendre c'est
déjà les mesures que j'ai prises pour la
rentrée 89 parce que nous avons créé
beaucoup plus de postes dans le budget
89 que l'année dernière
et quand j'ai vu les difficultés en cat
de la rentrée 88
j'ai demandé au gouvernement de donner
des postes supplémentaires j'ai obtenu
1000 postes de plus dans les lycées 800
postes d'instituteurs de plus et 500
postes dans les univers si kun est
encore sûr changé bien sûr nous ne
raterons pas alors ne disons pas aux
français que nous allons rattraper un
retard qui date de plus de dix ans en un
budget ça n'est pas possible on aurait
d'ailleurs pas les profs formés
comment on pourrait les former en les
mettant dans les postes il faut aussi
que ce soit de bon enseignant devant les
élèves
mais par un programme de pré recrutement
des enseignants et par des créations de
postes plus nombreuses on va répondre
progressivement la préoccupation de
cette maman deuxième problème la lecture
heureusement il ya quand même beaucoup
d'enfants qui arrive en 6e en sachant
lire mais c'est vrai qu'à des problèmes
et je demandais à un de nos meilleurs
recteur le recteur me
donc qui a beaucoup travaillé sur ces
questions de remplir une ce que
j'appellerais une mission lecture il va
me faire des propositions précises pour
améliorer l'apprentissage de la lecture
et je veux d'ailleurs centrer davantage
l'école primaire sur les apprentissages
fondamentaux lecture calcul écriture
alors ce que vous avez dit surtout sur
la première réponse ça nous amène au
problème des sous de la revalorisation
de la fonction d'enseignant
on oublie alors je voudrais vous êtes
vous avez annoncé aujourd'hui une
indemnité pour les professeurs du
secondaire 500 francs par mois c'est
déjà pas mal c'est un début mais ce que
vous n'avez pas un peu oublier ce qu'on
pourrait appeler le pilier de
l'éducation nationale c'est à dire les
trois cent mille instituteurs
certains gagnent moins de 6000 francs
par mois qui ce soir sont peut-être un
peu déçu mais ça nous amène d'abord à
comprendre avec l'autre que cette loi
d'orientation l effet de très grands
objectifs parce qu'il faut une grande
ambition pour notre pays et son école
mais elle est faite aussi de réponses à
des problèmes concrets que connaissent
les parents problème des rites quand
même des check points de redoublement le
problème des suivis des enfants et celui
et toussaint et c'est pourquoi je crois
que l'accueil n'a pas été mauvais
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure par les partenaires
alors c'est dans ce cadre qu on a
discuté aujourd'hui des problèmes que
vous dites de gros sous mais les
enseignants ils s'intéressent pas
simplement gros sous il s'intéresse à
leurs conditions de travail s'intéresse
à leur formation
elle se laisse pas mal oui ça compte
pour eux ils sont comme d'autres
salariés c'est normal alors on en a
parlé aujourd'hui moi je suis arrivé au
nom du gouvernement avec une enveloppe
qui est d'environ 10 milliards de francs
sur cinq ans les syndicats ont eu
tendance à dire c'est pas assez
peut-être mais ça n'est pas rien c'est
vrai qu'on regarde la situation
vous avez l'impression que ça pourra
couvrir les besoins comment vous précise
yann découvre pas non les besoins du
système éducatif qu'ils doivent être
couverts par l'effort accru qu'a décidé
le gouvernement ça c'est la priorité sur
les jeunes les besoins des enseignants
je veux dire que
les enseignants font leur métier et sont
payés moi j'arrive avec des mesures
positives qui ne sont peut-être pas tout
ce qu'il souhaite
mais qui ont un caractère positif les
instituteurs les instituteurs il est
prévu d'une part d'augmenter les débuts
de carrière d'accélérer ses débuts de
carrière
il est prévu également ce qu'on appelle
un grade de débouchés c'est à dire que
au fond une bonne partie d'entre eux
pourront arriver à des indices qui les
rapprocheront des indices actuels des
professeurs alors c'est une démarche
c'est une démarche dans le sens du
rapprochement
et n'oublions pas quand même que les
instituteurs ont été revalorisés en 81 2
mais aussi leurs salaires sont trop
faibles je le sais est qu'il faut aussi
penser aux enseignants des lycées
collèges et aux enseignants du supérieur
parce que vous le savez bien
dominique laurie les tensions actuelles
elles sont surtout dans les lycées et
dans les universités mais a compensé à
tout le monde merci hélène j'ose pas
céder à ce sujet sur lequel nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir de toute façon il
est très vaste le reste de l'actualité
maintenant avec d'abord la belgique
aucune nouvelle de paul vanden boeynants
l'ancien premier ministre disparu depuis
samedi dernier de son domicile
la justice belge écarte les
revendications présentées ces jours
derniers par des interlocuteurs se
réclamant de groupes terroristes et ce
soir le fils de vdb a lancé tout à
l'heure dont vous allez voir un appel
écoutez ma mère mes soeurs et moi même
sommes très inquiets car nous n'avons à
ce jour aucun signe de vie de mon père
contrairement à certaines informations
nous n'avons aucun contact avec les
ravisseurs
donc aucune négociation n'est en cours
nous regrettons certaines insinuations
que d'aucuns croient pouvoir formuler à
l'égard d'un homme qui ne peut se
défendre en belgique toujours le procès
du stade du heysel
les hooligans britanniques sont jugés à
bruxelles pour ce match de coupe
d'europe qui avait mal tourné en 85 et
où 39
on avait trouvé la mort dans les
tribunes mais le procès a montré que les
wigan ce n'était pas seule en cause
cet après midi c'était le réquisitoire
isabelle des fleurs à bruxelles trois à
quatre ans de prison pour 15 et vous
ligan dont la responsabilité est établie
voilà ce que le procureur du roi a
requis ce soir les juges apprécieront
pour huit autres supporters anglais dont
la responsabilité n'a pas été établi de
manière formelle deux autres devraient
être acquittés faute de preuves
le procureur du roi n'a pas ménagé ses
coups de patte aux supporters anglais
qui l'accusé d'être des spécialistes du
double langage déguisé en premier
communiant par commodité du côté des
inculpés pas de réaction l'urgence ce
soir était de rentrer à liverpool
les élus et les responsables de la
municipalité de bruxelles qui est
propriétaire du stade du heysel ont été
mis hors de cause par le procureur de
même plus les responsables de l'uefa
l'union européenne de football amateur
en revanche le procureur a mis au pilori
les leaders de l'union belge de football
pour avoir privilégié le profit au
détriment de la sécurité de même pour
les forces de l'ordre des organisations
bureaucratisme et manque d'initiative se
sont donc l'union belge de football et
l'état belge qui auront à indemniser les
victimes de la soirée sanglante du 29
mai 1985 au stade du heysel
oui et c'est cette semaine justement que
le gouvernement britannique présenté son
projet de loi anti hooligans les
britanniques tentent de d'endiguer ce
phénomène qui empoisonnent tous les
matchs de foot en grande bretagne
excluant même les équipes britanniques
des coupes d'europe maintenant mais le
projet le projet donc anti hooligans
présenté mardi et déjà vous allez le
voir très controversé jean ma mère la
plaie du football britannique ne se
trouve pas sur le terrain mais bien dans
ces tribunes l'angleterre ne sait plus
comment arrêter cette vague de
hooliganisme qui frappe régulièrement
les grands clubs le samedi après midi
tout le monde se souvient du réel les
anglais particulièrement et ils ne
veulent plus être la honte de l'europe
pour remédier à ce fléau le gouvernement
mettant projet pour le printemps
prochain une carte individuelle
elles seraient attribuées aux supporters
par le club pour pouvoir assister aux
matchs à l'étranger note
man tous supporters voyageant sans cette
carte est menacée de 4000 francs
d'amendé et de prison
quant au club qui ne respecteraient pas
la règle il jouerait dans un stade vide
ou père et 20 mille francs d'amendé par
infraction constatée
seules exceptions admises les familles à
condition qu'elles assistent aux
rencontres dans des loges réservé à cet
effet et les handicapés premier problème
cette carte de supporters coûterait 800
millions de francs la ligue de football
et pourrait bien être fatal
financièrement à bon nombre de petits
clubs
autre problème d'éthique celui là et qui
soulève en ce moment grande polémique au
sein du parlement pour les travaillistes
le parti d'opposition
cette carte est une grave atteinte à la
liberté elle reviendrait à imposer une
sorte de carte d'identité nationale
or les britanniques n'ont jamais eu
devoir de porter sur eux
quelques papiers que ce soit françois
mitterrand bulgarie depuis ce matin une
visite de deux jours dans un pays avec
lequel la france entretient très peu de
contacts c'est d'ailleurs la première
fois qu'un président de la république
française sera en bulgarie c'est un pays
de 9 millions d'habitants qui passe pour
le plus fidèle allié de l'union
soviétique
compte rendu de cette première journée
de voyage georges bortoli la bulgarie
s'est mise en prêt pour recevoir le
premier chef d'état français qu'il ait
jamais visité depuis la création de ce
petit état balte avis il y as envie
c'est un joli froid sec
il y a accueilli monsieur mitterrand qui
en a profité pour se rendre à pied au
palais de boya nain où l'attendaient les
signatures de plusieurs protocoles
destinés à relancer les relations
économiques bien faible entre la france
et la bulgarie qui n'est que le 70e
clients de notre pays ou n'attendez
surtout le doyen incontesté des chefs
d'état de l'europe de l'est totor giscop
77 ans au pouvoir depuis 1954
monsieur jivkov lance quelques appels à
l'initiative privée pour relancer une
économie qui est un morne mais il suit
avec réticence le vent de libéralisation
venus de moscou
l'académicien chez nous tu qu d'hier à
demain matin au petit déjeuner à
monsieur mitterrand que la paire istres
okala gorbatchev passe mal à sofia et la
poétesse blaga dimitra 20 dira au
président français que son habitation de
demain matin est un ballon d'oxygène
pour les contestataires modérer les
autres n'ont pas droit de cité cette
havrais connaissance de notre travail
aussi mes collègues écrivains qui sont
parmi les invités c'est un grand
événement pour nos pas seulement
politique mais aussi culturel donc vous
pensez que cette visite du président de
la république peut avoir des effets
positifs sur la libéralisation en
bulgarie cette question des droits de
l'homme est évidemment une des deux
grandes différences entre europe de
l'ouest et europe de l'est
l'autre différence étant bien sûr celle
des systèmes économiques
malgré ces différences monsieur
mitterrand pense que les deux moitiés de
l'europe vont quelque peu se rapprocher
dans les temps à venir
d'où cette série de voyages dans les
pays de cette europe si l'autre europe
comme il aime à le dire
strasbourg sur la sellette en tant que
capitale européenne bien sûr strasbourg
c'est le siège du parlement européen
vous le savez mais beaucoup voudrait
transférer ce parlement en partie du
moins
à bruxelles les députés européens en
discuter cet après-midi et strasbourg
risque bien d'y avoir perdu un peu de
ses attributions christian mary mono
a strasbourg le parlement européen
choisi son lieu de travail après une
journée où les violentes batailles de
procédure les parlementaires ont préféré
bruxelles ils ont adopté 11 le rapport
de ce député britannique derk prague
l'homme qui a enflammé les esprits le
président flémin bien tenté de lui
apporter la réplique
la france voulait garder comme unique
siège du parlement européen à strasbourg
mais dans le même temps bruxelles
construit un nouveau parlement européen
à quelques mètres de l'exécutif la
commission et autres atouts de bruxelles
et non des moindres ses nombreuses
dessertes aériennes double atout donc
dans la capitale belge
lorsque le parlement a envisagé
l'installation de ces commissions
il a déjà à l'époque choisi cette
implantation parce qu'elle était à côté
des autres installations européennes
donc du futur complexe du conseil des
ministres de la commission du berlaymont
et puis parce qu'il y avait encore là
bas une possibilité d'extension pour
l'ancien président est pierre pelé main
l'esprit européen doit dépasser ces
querelles matériel vous institutions
européennes ne sont pas faites pour les
parlementaires européennes et pour les
fonctionnaires européens
les institutions européennes doivent
correspondre à quelque chose dans
l'esprit dans le coeur des gens pourtant
la france s'était engagée au plus haut
niveau
le président françois mitterrand avait
adressé ses voeux depuis la capitale
alsacienne
un symbole politique et puis la ville
s'était mobilisé également avec une
campagne d' affiches originales et de
nombreuses vedettes cet hémicycle
restaurative vide pas dans l'immédiat
strasbourg a cependant se soit perdu la
bataille la parole au chef d'état le
président marcos au plus mal l'ex
président philippin est hospitalisée
pour des complications respiratoires les
son état se serait brusquement aggravé
ce soir en pologne l'adoption par le
comité central du parti du principe de
pluralisme politique et syndicale
cette adoption n'a satisfait apparemment
ni le parti ni l'opposition
il s'agissait vous le savez de
reconnaître éventuellement le syndicat
solidarité mais les conditions qui y
sont assortis rendent solidarnosc très
sceptique
d'autres informations internationales
avec roland sicard
patrick purdy 24 ans et auteur d'un
véritable carnage
la scène se passe à stockton en
californie après avoir mis le feu à sa
voiture le meurtrier pénètre dans cette
école mitraillette à la main et ouvre
l'oeuf
trente personnes sont blessées cinq
enfants âgés de 6 à 9 ans ont tué puis
le meurtre y retourne son arme contre
lui
il n'aura donné aucune explication
la ville de miami aux états unis en état
de siège pour la deuxième nuit
consécutive lundi que je noir avec des
thés est battu par des policiers
aussi tant les habitants des quartiers
noirs étaient descendus dans la rue et
me pillages violences au total 230
personnes ont été arrêtées
roberto paulo va pouvoir revoir ses
tableaux du mois ceux qui n'ont pas
encore été saisis
l'expert d'art avec les remis en liberté
provisoire c'est son état de santé qui a
incité la justice italienne à la
clémence arrêté en juin dernier
roberto paulo est accusé d'avoir
détourné plusieurs centaines de millions
de francs
un grand succès pour l'industrie
française et particulièrement les
hélicoptères après quatre années
d'incertitude les hélicos de
l'aérospatiale sont maintenant numéro un
sur le marché américain et oui c'est
pourtant là que les constructeurs
d'hélicoptères sont les plus nombreux et
les plus compétitifs
patrick esther un hélicoptère civil sur
quatre vendus en amérique du nord en
1988 est sorti des usines de la filiale
d'aérospatiale installés ici à grand
prairie au texas un exploit au pays où
les concurrents s'appellent sikorski
belle mcdonnell douglas use les usines
aérospatiale qui perd des 300 millions
de francs il ya quatre ans ont coiffé au
poteau ses géants de l'aéronautique et
conquis la toute première place grâce à
de nouvelles techniques de production et
de ventes l'an dernier
aérospatiale a conforté son rang de
premier exportateur mondial toutes
catégories confondues sur plus de 9
milliards de francs de commandes
enregistré 70 % l'ont été à
l'exportation monsieur paul est sous les
verrous monsieur paul est un escroc
d'envergure son vrai nom paul ii sort à
croire qu'il n'a jamais cessé les
escroqueries toute sa vie en est
jalonnée sa dernière une énorme affaire
de placements fictifs à chartres mais ce
qui c'est sans doute ce qui l'a fait
tomber
isabelle streiff au coeur du brouillard
chartrain la ténébreuse affaire de
monsieur paul
ici tout le monde le connaît en
apparence un monsieur bien sous tous
rapports
bénévole au secours catholique ce
banquier défroqué avait rêvé d'être curé
les soeurs du couvent de bourgneuf
l'accueillait dans cette modeste demeure
une figure locale comme on dit il
fréquente est la bonne bourgeoisie
et les meilleures tables de la ville
c'est un homme très très chaud vial très
gentil très polis ajouté courtois et un
petit peu vert qui menait son petit
aperçu sur le dos très très accroc est
habitué à le voir mais tiens voilà
monsieur paul insoupçonnable monsieur
paul
comment imaginer qu il était en fait un
escroc de longue date
à chartres il dirigeait une société de
placement financier un rendement
exceptionnel mais la moitié des actions
proposées étaient fictives
plus de mille personnes se sont laissées
piéger d'autres ont été plus vigilante
je me suis dit c'est pas possible on
peut pas en allant gagner le double de
ce que l'on pense que l'on place même et
en ignorant des mécanismes boursiers
mais s'il ya un coup d'arnac derrière
tout ça 10% dans mois déjà quand on a la
caisse d'epargne que vous en ont 3 % par
an on se dit qu'il doit y avoir quelque
chose de louche le dessous bénéfices
empochés par la société finance horizon
couverture à paris de cette gigantesque
escroquerie 500 millions de francs
tous les coupables de monsieur paul sont
déjà sous les verrous mais il a fait des
émules en europe selon les services de
police
l'extorsion de fonds atteindre les 8
milliards de francs un sondage sur le
sida qui apporte des informations très
intéressantes
un sondage ifop publié par la revue
impact médecin 35 % des médecins
auraient déjà prescrit un test de
dépistage du sida sans avoir averti
leurs patients et ce chiffre inquiétant
s'élèverait même à 56% chez les médecins
hospitaliers la marche de la mort de
georges schéhadé c'était un poète
libanais qui écrivait en français qui
avait dû quitter le liban il ya une
dizaine d'années depuis la guerre ces
pièces de théâtre sont les pièces
françaises les plus joués dans le monde
après lyonnais cris ionesco et des
quêtes georges schéhadé mort à l'âge de
81 ans
il était une fois un jeune homme de
rennes qui s'est élancé dans le rock
pour oublier un chagrin d'amour cette
semaine il est au zénith je veux parler
bien sûr de la salle qui accueille les
meilleurs chanteurs son nom c'est
etienne daho
il a travaillé pour les plus grands il
est maintenant tout seul en scène un
tour de chant qu'il a rôdé dans toute la
france gérard dalmaz
etienne daho ne fait d'ombré à personne
il a choisi de raviver la flamme
romantique au bonheur non dissimulé de
ces accros 17 à 30 ans au fait qu'est ce
qui leur plaît
quoi
j'aime bien basculer il est timide mais
quand on est sur scène il est vraiment
bien voyez il se sortir de cette
immunité pour pour nous moi j'ai
retrouvé un peu de tendresse ma faim
peut rêver ses chansons et c'est pour ça
que j'écoute etienne daho parce que
j'aime bien que ça romantique s'étendre
et puis la dao magna est en marche
un million de disques déjà ce licencié
dans l'air raconte qu'il apprend encore
à chanter alors qu'il est souvent
directeur artistique
exemple avec daniel darc ici en studio
et qu'il compose pour françoise hardy
entre autres pas très showbiz plutôt
lucky luke dao nous apprivoise avec son
voile de spleen dans la gorge
les gens s'identifient certaines de ses
chansons et que ça les touche je crois
que c'est ça mon attitude depuis tout
début où ça marchait pas du tout n'a pas
changé
mon optique est toujours la même donc
s'efforcer dans les gens qui sont venus
vers moi pourquoi j'en sais rien il
était peut-être il avait peut-être envie
avant d'écouter ses chansons là mon
propos étant d'idéaliser en fait
finalement tout ce qui est quotidien
donc c'est très très banal finances très
simple ça permet de rendre peut-être un
petit peu plus coloré ou un petit peu
plus attrayant une situation un lieu où
quelqu'un
demain il ya un tiers fait c'est moins
poétique mais peut-être plus lucratifs
peut-être en tout cas si vous suivez les
pronostics de pierrette brès est à
vincennes voici les pronostics
13 11 17 16 5/20 as et six dans un
instant une météo gris et brouillard ce
sera sophie davant qui zonent qui vous
annoncera ses nouvelles médiocres et
puis la dernière édition du journal ce
sera ce soir en direct d'avoriaz ce pour
le festival du film fantastique bien sûr
ce sera henri sannier vers 23h20 à
demain soir 20h
à